THAT’S THERE AND WELCOME
BACK.
[INAUDIBLE]
NOW THAT SCHOOLS ARE TAKING
YOUR TAX MONEY AND NOT EVEN
OPENING THEIR DOORS TO
STUDENTS, THIS COULD BE A
BREAKTHROUGH MOMENT.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THAT NOW.
CORY, LOOK, I DON’T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE PRINCIPAL, WE
ALL AGREE IN SCHOOL CHOICE,
I’VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR.
WHAT I’M INTERESTED IN HEARING
IS THE OPTIONS THAT ARE
THERE.
IT’S NOT JUST CHARTER SCHOOLS
PROVIDED BY LOCAL, ENABLED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
INNOVATION AND ENTREPRENEURIAL
ACTIVITY IS REALLY GIVING
PARENTS LOTS OF NEW AND
DIFFICULT OPTIONS.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THEM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN GETTING THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK WHEN IT
COMES TO K-12 EDUCATION FOR A
LONG TIME.
LIKE YOU SAID, THE LOCKDOWN
SITUATION IN THE SCHOOL
REOPENING HAS REALLY MADE THAT
CLEAR NOW THAN MORE THAN EVER
BECAUSE FAMILIES ARE POWERLESS
IN THE WAY TO FIX THIS IS TO
FUND FAMILIES DIRECTLY JUST
LIKE WE DO WITH A HOST OF
OTHER INITIATIVES WHETHER
THAT’S PELL GRANTS AT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION LEVEL, PRE-K
PROGRAMS, THAT ALSO DEALS WITH
EDUCATION AND FOOD STAMPS, THE
MONEY GOES DIRECTLY TO
FAMILIES AND FAMILIES CAN PICK
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS AND WE
SHOULD DO THE EXACT SAME THING
FOR K-12 AND IF YOU’D LIKE WE
CAN CALL IT UBI, UNIVERSAL
BASIC EDUCATION.
HAVE THE FUNDING GO TO THE
FAMILIES AND WE SHOULD FUND
STUDENTS INSTEAD OF SCHOOL
SYSTEMS JUST LIKE WE DO WITH
ALL THESE OTHER PROGRAMS, AND
LIKE YOU ASKED THERE’S A WHOLE
HOST OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS
BESIDES CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THERE’S MAGNET SCHOOLS,
VIRTUAL CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
OTHER STATES WERE BLOCKING
FAMILIES FROM SWITCHING TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WELL SUCH
AS CALIFORNIA, PENNSYLVANIA SO
WE MAY SEE LAWSUIT LAWSUITS IN
OTHER STATES LIKE THAT SO
THERE’S ALSO PROGRAMS WHERE
THE FUNDING GOES TO THE FAMILY
IN THE FORM OF A VOUCHER AND
THEY CAN TAKE IT TO THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL OF THEIR
CHOOSING OR EVEN A MICRO
SCHOOL WHICH GETS ME TO IT
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
EDUCATION SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
WHICH IS AGAIN LIKE A VOUCHER
IDEA BUT IT GOES TO THE FAMILY
AND YOU CAN USE IT FOR
TUTORING SERVICES, ONLINE
PROVIDERS AND THEIR ALREADY
HAVE BEEN FAMILIES GETTING
TOGETHER IN LARGE NUMBERS
ACROSS UNITED STATES.
THE WASHINGTON POST JUST WROTE
ABOUT IT WHERE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING TOGETHER IN GROUPS OF
TEN, FIVE TO TEN STUDENTS IN
ONE HOUSEHOLD AND THEIR
ESSENTIALLY OUTSOURCING THE
PROCESS OF HOMESCHOOLING AND
THIS IS CALLED MICRO SCHOOLS
SO I WOULD RECOMMEND LOOKING
AT MICRO SCHOOLS OR HOMESCHOOL
CO-OPS IN YOUR AREA TO CHECK
THIS OUT.
JUST THINK ABOUT IT.
WE’D SPEND OVER $15000.
CHILD.
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
JUST IMAGINE IF THAT FAMILY
WENT TO FAMILIES DIRECTLY AND
YOU GOT TEN STUDENTS, JUST
IMAGINE IF ONLY A THIRD OF
THAT WENT TO OVERHEAD COST.
THE TEACHER WOULD STILL HAVE
AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS LEFT OVER AND THIS
COULD BENEFIT TEACHERS A LOT
IF THEY’RE IN HIGH DEMAND AND
IT COULD BENEFIT FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS AS WELL TO GET THESE
OPTIONS AND I WILL SAY THIS
WOULD BENEFIT THE LEAST
ADVANTAGE MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE BECAUSE THERE’S ALREADY
VERY ADVANTAGE FAMILIES GOING
AROUND IN THE U.S. FORMING
THESE GROUPS.
IT’S THE LEAST ADVANTAGE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE TROUBLING
FINDING THESE OPTIONS AND SO
WE SHOULD FUND THEM DIRECTLY
AND ALLOW THEM TO FIND THESE
OPTIONS SO EVERYBODY CAN HAVE
EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS, NOT JUST
THE MOST ADVANTAGED IN
SOCIETY.
>> YOU ARE SO GOOD AT THIS.
YOU ANSWERED ALL THE QUESTIONS
THAT I WAS GOING TO PUT YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THINK WE SHOULD MAKE YOU
EDUCATION SECRETARY.
THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
FANTASTIC.
I LOVE THE CONVERSATION OF
MICRO SCHOOLS AS A TWIST TO
HOMESCHOOLING.
THAT’S REALLY INTERESTING.
WE WILL STAY IN TOUCH AS OUR
CAMPAIGN MOVES FORWARD FOR THE
MOMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING BACK KIM AND
STEVE.
KIM, I JUST THINK, YOU’VE
HEARD THAT WHOLE CONVERSATION,
MY CALL FORGETTING PEOPLE,
GETTING THEIR MONEY BACK, IF
THEY’RE NOT GETTING WHAT THEY
WANT IN TERMS OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OPENING SCHOOLS, ALL
THESE INNOVATIVE OPTIONS, NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO DELIVER THE
EDUCATION, I THINK IT’S A
REALLY EXCITING MOMENT
POTENTIALLY.
>> I THINK IT’S ENORMOUS
BECAUSE IT’S PUSHING
EVERYTHING TO THE FLOOR, AND
LET ME POINT OUT WHO’S REALLY
PUSHING IT TO THE FLOOR.
IT’S THE UNION.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
ONLY REFUSING TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN BUT SETTING UP
INCREDIBLY HIGH HURDLES IN
ORDER TO AGREE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND EVEN DEMANDING MORE
FROM THINGS LIKE THE L.A.
TEACHERS UNION WHICH THIS WEEK
SAID IT WOULDN’T GO BACK TO
SCHOOL UNLESS IT GOT MEDICARE
FOR ALL, ANOTHER BAILOUT AN
END TO CHARTER SCHOOLS AND NOW
YOU HAVE GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
CALIFORNIA SAYING EVEN THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS CAN’T REOPEN,
THAT’S A PROTECTION FOR
TEACHERS UNIONS BECAUSE HE
KNEW SOME PARENTS WOULD BE
BEGINNING TO LOOK AT THESE
OPTIONS BECAUSE THOSE SCHOOLS
WERE GOING (WHAT I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE, STEVE, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE ANOTHER FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS BILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
STANDARDS AND RULES PUT INTO
IT ABOUT HOW THE MONEY THAT
HAS ALREADY GONE OUT AND
STATES CAN BE USED AND MAKE
CLEAR THAT IT CAN BE USED BY
ANY DISTRICTS THAT ARE NOT
OPENING AND EDUCATING KIDS.
>> YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW THIS
COULD ACTUALLY ACCELERATE
SOMETHING THAT WE’VE ALL BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR FOR MANY YEARS,
THE WHOLE SCHOOL CHOICE
MOVEMENT.
>> YOU STARTED ASKING KIM AT
THE START OF THE SHOW WHAT
COULD PRESIDENT TRUMP DO
UNILATERALLY TO GET THIS
ECONOMY MOVING.
HOW ABOUT THIS.
I KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP WATCHES
YOUR SHOW, MR. PRESIDENT, GIVE
EVERYTHING A PARENT IN A
DISTRICT WHERE THE SCHOOLS ARE
NOT GOING TO OPEN UP, I LIVE
IN ONE OF THEM, GIVE EVERY
PARENT A 10000-DOLLAR FEDERAL
VOUCHER.
WE SPENT $50 BILLION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND LET THE
PARENTS GO TO SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE, IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD,
EXACTLY WHAT YOU GUYS WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT WHERE FOUR
OR FIVE PARENTS ARE GETTING
TOGETHER.
THEY WILL TEACH THE KIDS.
WHY NOT LET THE MONEY GO TO
THE PARENTS AND THE SCHOOLS SO
THAT OUR KIDS GET A DECENT
EDUCATION THIS FALL.
>> I LOVE IT.
THIS IS SO EXCITING BECAUSE
THE WHOLE VOUCHER THING,
THAT’S WHY I DID THAT MY
SCHOOL MONEY BACK THEN BECAUSE
IT’S FRUSTRATING.
EVEN THOUGH WERE ALL IN
FAVORITE YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR YOUR
LOCAL AUTHORITY TO DO THE
VOUCHER BUT YOU’RE RIGHT, THE